sie versüßt ihr die weihnachtszeit
du siehst du die laizer zugeschneit dich
mit packen vom alter gefragt
ich will
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute geht ein leckeres plätzchen rezept
ich werde heute quark steuern konfekt
machen das ist der borat nämlich immer
ganz gerne und wir haben dieses jahr
keinen großen stollen deswegen habe ich
darauf komme aber quark stoll
die sind sehr schnell hergestellt und
wirklich auch super lecker und man kann
es einfach so verlassen können so gut
portioniert man kann sie gut passieren
gut verschenken und deswegen finde ich
dir immer ganz praktisch und ich hab
mich heute für ein tolles quatschen
rezept entschieden ich zeige mich jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten und sag euch
aber auch dann was ihr zum beispiel
austausche und ersetzen könnte ja ich
sehe was was du nicht mal genau hier die
grundzutaten ich habe hier 100 gramm
weiche butter 75 g zucker 1 prise salz
etwas vanille extrakt das können auf
keinen fall ersetzen die grundzutat bei
mir zuhause 150 gramm quark da können
dann ganz normalen magerquark oder auch
in sahne quark benutzen
300 gramm mehl 125 teelöffel backpulver
1 teelöffel zimt eine orangene bio
orange ich hab jetzt aber moralisch
mcquaid gebracht
graz apa es ist eine biografie aber egal
mit wie jetzt dann habe ich hier 100
gramm gehackte mandeln 100 gramm
marzipanrohmasse 100 gramm rosinen und
etwa 60 bis 70 milliliter apfelsaft zu
der roma sie konsole sorgen
maspalomas genau da habe ich eine
lübecker marzipanrohmasse das ist
einfach das beste marzipan finde ich was
man findet weil einfach sehr viel
mandeln enthalten sind weniger zucker
und man so einfach denn richtig toll
marzipan geschmack hat genommen da bist
nur lübecker marzipan entwicklers mit
wenn es wirklich ausgiebig herum und es
heißt auch sehr qualitativ hochwertigen
uhren bei über 80 prozent
genau dankeschön und noch mal ganz kurz
zu meinem vertrag natürlich können jedes
mal extrakt auch ersetzen durch
vanillezucker aber geschmacklich ist es
war nicht extra natürlich viel besser
weil es einfach echte vanille ist so
dann starten wir direkt mit dem teig
also zuerst kommt jetzt die butter in
eine rührschüssel und ihr könnt es
natürlich auch ein handrührgerät machen
oder auch mit den händen wenn ihr wollt
dann kommt der zucker mit rein und etwas
salz und die vanille und dann wird es
erst mal ganz kurz cremig gerührt
also vanille gebe ich bei plätzchen
rezepte nimmer etwas mehr mit dazu weil
ich finde da kann es richtig toll nach
vanille schmecken
also da kann man das gut
jetzt gebe ich noch den apfelsaft zu den
rosinen mit dazu natürlich könnt ihr an
der stelle einfach auch etwas rum
benutzen
warum ist es dann auch so dass den
könnte auch schon einen tag vorher mit
zu den russinen geben dann zieht ziel
die rosinen in rom auch richtig gut ein
natürlich auch beim apfelsaft so und es
macht mir einfach damit die russinen
jetzt während dem backen einfach nicht
verbrennen
beim google macht macht zum beispiel
auch so dass sie eben dann nicht unten
in der tag ein sinken sondern einfach
schön im teig mit drin bleiben und wenn
ihr gar keine rosinen wollen lasst
einfach weg aber die flüssigkeit muss
auf jeden fall mit in den teig so dann
einfach gut vermischen
dann geht's jetzt weiter im teig da gebe
ich jetzt den quark mit dazu da kann ich
hier schon mal die trockenen zutaten
vermischen und auch bereits die
orangenschale bzw bei mir jetzt die raid
brutale abreibung
als nächstes schreibe ich auch das
marzipan schön sein wenn du was übrig
bleibt kann mich sogar
ja ich hab dir die andere hälfte einfach
mit aufgehoben schmidt es auch
jetzt gehen wir einfach alle zutaten mit
in die rührschüssel und dann verrät ich
so schön miteinander
total geil
jetzt habe ich hier zwei backbleche mit
backpapier gerichtet und jetzt werden
die das staunen konfektioniert ich nehme
jetzt dafür so einen letzten
portionierer mit dem mache ich auch
immer ganz gerne die makronen die habe
ich auch im letzten jahr schon gemacht
könnte auf jeden fall mal bei mir in den
rezepten schauen da habe ich die mit
drin und mit dem kann man eben auch gut
dieses quark stollen konfektionieren und
zwar kann ich das hier doch einfach
draufsetzen
oder wenn ihr den jetzt nicht abgehen
natürlich auch zwei teelöffel aber mit
dem geht es halt schon viel schneller
kann jetzt auch roh essen
den teig ja sicher auch kein ei mit drin
war zu sanieren hat er schon aufgegessen
der abriss aufstand von daher richtung
trotzdem richtig rosig
also gescher hatte ich auch keine
rosinen drin ich hab sie weggelassen
aber ich finde somit rufen ist es
eigentlich auch ganz gut was vermag
keine rosinen ist weiß ich ja jemand ich
mache auch keine rosinen die kunden nach
mir vielleicht ändert sie ihre meinung
und so wie das konfekt jetzt im backofen
bei 200 grad ober und unterhitze für
ungefähr zehn bis dreizehn minuten
gebacken bis die oberfläche goldbraun
ist
das quark schon kontakt ist fertig und
jetzt ist es noch ganz warm und ich
werde jetzt direkt weiterverarbeiten
also wenn ihr gedacht habe das war's
jetzt schon meinen dass wir noch nichts
kommen noch ein paar kalorien mit dazu
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier bereits 100
gramm geschmolzene butter und ich habe
hier etwa 125 bis 150 gramm puderzucker
und jetzt muss das konfekt zur heiß wie
es noch ist direkt erstmal in die mutter
einmal drin wälzen
man könnte es auch so lassen aber dann
ist hat noch kein richtiges klappstühle
konfekt muss auf jeden fall puderzucker
noch drauf dann nehmt ihr sie heraus und
direkt in den puderzucker mit rein
und jetzt auch direkt futter zucker
obendrüber also die sollen schön damit
bedeckt sein
und dann kann ich schon direkt raus
nehmen
wir sind jetzt fertig ich habe jetzt das
quatschen konfekt zwar schon auf dem
teller angerichtet
um euch zu zeigen aber damit richtig gut
schmeckt müsste es auf jeden fall über
nacht in einer luftdichten schale
verpacken und stehen lassen unser mira
zeigt euch ihren adventskalender von
massow den vom papa von juristen selbst
gebastelten so ist es dennoch kaufte ich
finde es interessant dass man für 570
gramm schokolade dann so viel geld ich
habe jetzt hier noch für den murat habe
ich hier noch ein t
murat das ist jetzt kein kinder punkt
oder kein glühwein oder so nicht einfach
eine tür geschlossen weil sie keine am
liebsten trinkt und ich habe ich dennoch
deine drei kekse mit dazu gelegt 3 gib
mir dein gott gibt mir einfach die taste
um die ganzen teller alles klar so
machen ist auf jeden fall finde ich ist
dieses quark stoll konfekt wirklich
super schnell hergestellt
eine nacht ruhen lassen dann ist es auch
richtig schön weich und durchgezogen und
schmeckt wirklich hervorragend wobei ich
finde es schmeckt jetzt auch schon gut
ablaufen wird
der teller wird die nachricht bestehen
ja ich hab noch in der fraktion und die
verstecke ich gleich vom rat muss ich
sowieso jedes jahr mit dem ganze
weihnachtsgebäck woche war langsam
sticht immer viel zu schnell leer
sascha cdu nur warten bis zum ersten
dezember
wir machen das jetzt schon mal auf und
ihr dürft das rezept gern nachlesen auf
meinem blog auf sallys - viel spaß beim
nachhaken bis zum nächsten mal sujets
und schaut euch auf jeden fall auch um
die anderen weihnachtskonzerten also die
plätzchen rezepte auch die vom letzten
jahr hatte ich nicht mal öffnen morath
denn 75 gramm ding her denn gar nicht
öffnen
die